My name is Arturo Fontes.
I was an FBI agent for
approximately 28 years.
People laugh at me because
I left sunny San Diego
with beaches and everything
and a nice big house
to be in a small
town, in Laredo.
They call it "the
armpit" of Texas.
[honking]
It takes you all
the way into Dallas,
and it even goes all the
way up North in the US.
Now this is an
area where there
was the biggest number of trucks
crossing the whole border.
It was a very important route.
The Gulf Cartel was
shipping marijuana,
cocaine, heroin through Texas
to across the United States.
The Gulf Cartel was
onto a good thing,
but it was about to get a
whole lot better with the North
American Free Trade Agreement.
PRESIDENT CLINTON: And after
we'll pare down trade barriers
between our three
nations, it will create
the world's largest trade zone.
Today we have the chance to do
what our parents did before us.
We have the opportunity
to remake the world.
ARTURO FONTES: In
Nuevo Laredo, it's
more important than almost
any other area in Mexico,
and that's why it's
a battleground.
It's a crown jewel for drug
trafficking-- everybody
wants that.
MIKE CHAVARRIA: Osiel was a
genius at being able to read
people and manipulate them.
He was brilliant at
influencing people to do things
that they shouldn't be doing.
In the special
forces, they had
radio code with the zed letter.
So they would have,
like, [speaking spanish]..
They're be like, you
know, Z2, I'm on alert.
They quickly became called
"The Zetas," or "The Zeds,"
after that radio code.
MIKE CHAVARRIA: Osiel
saw in them a discipline
that your regular
trafficker did not have,
and that was a
militarized discipline.
A respect for chain
of command, loyalty,
the willing to attack
the hill when told,
regardless of the outcome.
We saw that the Zetas
were becoming a threat.
There was definitely
a foreboding
of things to come
as the Zetas began
to grow and become stronger.
And they were learning the drug
trade from the Gulf Cartel.
Osiel is definitely in the
crosshairs of the FBI and DEA.
He is public enemy number one.
[gunfire]
The arrest was like a scene
out of Afghanistan, Iraq.
[gunfire]
The Mexican military
I believe may
have lost one or two
soldiers during the course
of that gun battle.
[gunfire]
Osiel survived.
He was apprehended, but
it was quite the shootout.